[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
today's question it's a long one get
ready everyone it buckle up we got Barry
in New Jersey is my wife a princess or
do I need an attitude change yes and yes
all right let's get their numbers we
have followed your baby steps in our
debt free but the house our net worth is
1.6 million we owe 80,000 on the house
it's worth 700,000 we're 50 years old my
income's
125,000 every year early in our marriage
my wife made over 100,000 but we had two
kids and later we had two more we made
the decision for her to be home and
homeschool the kids all the way through
High School huge sacrifice both agreed
it was best for our family now fast
forward 20 years the kids are grown
we're doing well our lives and our
marriage are great but my wife is still
not working I have asked her to just
work to knock out the mortgage to take
that off my back and to help us build a
gap fund so I can retire a little early
she has shown little effort at finding
something and is not super motivated uh
we make plenty to live on but I've
noticed some of our budget drift as she
has more time on her hands and isn't
needing to spend devoted time to our
kids with schooling is she a princess
for not wanting to go back to work or do
I just need to suck it up and change my
attitude and be grateful for the fact
that she doesn't have to work I know my
need jerk I want you to go first because
I have a very clear answer uh I think he
needs an attitude change I don't think
she's being a princess she worked hard
with the kids she's a stay at home now
wife he's doing fine financially they
got 80k on the house they're going to
pay it off she's 50 plus years old she's
enjoying her life I agree but but I'm
not mad at her I'm not either but what
do you say in fact I'm G to stay out of
this and just ask a question okay let's
say that uh Barry's wife her name is
Mary just for fun okay and let's say you
and Mary go to tea or whatever ever you
would do and and she says my husband
Barry has asked me to go back to work
it's the same scenario sure and she says
to you we're fine all the things you
just said yeah but I understand he wants
to knock it out blah blah blah blah blah
these are he wants me to go back to work
and I just don't want to what should I
say to him how should we handle this
what would your advice be to your friend
Mary about her husband
Barry Mary and
Barry uh I would say I could understand
where he's coming from I can see more
for him wanting to retire early and
wanting to get out of the work and stuff
I see that more plausible and
understandable for some reason than even
the house I know but what do you say to
her because he's clearly brought this up
to her Y and she she's not moving FAS so
I would I would ask
her uh what is it that keeps you from
not working yes meaning like is it that
you don't have a thing that you're
passionate about that you want to do uh
is it that you just logically have come
to a conclusion that y'all are going to
be fine like you're going to pay off the
house soon yeah he will retire at a
decent age there's no need for this
urgency at this point in our lives um so
I would ask her those questions and then
I would have her I would I would want
her to ask him you know hey what what's
really like what is going on what's more
pressing do you get frustrated that I'm
just home is that bother you do you
think I'm like you know what I mean I
want to know cuz some resentment could
be building on his end could it be the
budget drift so he's like if she works
then she's going to keep her you know
she can't like and obviously she can't
go and just do whatever she want like we
have to have limits and boundaries in
life but it doesn't sound like she's out
of control at all and if they had two
car payments and $115,000 of credit card
debt she's she got she has to get back
to work all right so I want you to keep
on this cuz you're getting us there but
let me in interject on behalf of well
you get us there do you know do you know
where we're going well I yeah but where
you were going I wanted you to tell us
what you would tell her because I this
is a getting on the same page you're
great at that you're very intentional in
your life with Winston and so here's my
only take I think he sees her as
potential income and he's got some
stress and he's got some urgency over a
goal and he look he's looking at her in
this case wrongly sure fair with me I go
I understand what you see you see
potential income that's not being maxed
out and you're going come on babe yeah
that's what I think he's feeling so then
how does she that's what I'm so I just
wanted to throw that in there yeah so
what would you tell her cuz there's some
stress on his end uh there is and I just
wonder on her end hey is is there other
ways that I can help contribute to
lowering that stress with me not having
to go back to work like would it make
you feel better and and if we agreed on
a budget and I actually stuck to my word
right because if the budget's a drift
then there is a level of like someone's
not keeping their word which cannot it's
not great um so I would have those
conversations but I also think that
there's like a a reasonableness for him
to see yeah y'all are you guys are doing
fine yeah well if anytime someone
mentions twice the same phrase is she a
princess me thinks that Barry thinks
that she's a princess and what he means
by that is not the compliment it's like
you got it good babe I've been out
busting it yes you did your PR so I I
would say to Barry hey dude I'm guessing
there's already been a lot of tension
around this and you got to change your
tenor and how going at this cuz if
you're asking us twice and and a thing
that you know may get r on the air is
she a princess that tells me you are
feeling some resentment towards her
that's got to get fixed that's that's
more of the underlying issue and I do
think sometimes spouse is because our
spouse is the closest person in our
lives they are the ones that we can just
kind of like yeah you know say it all
give it all whatever um but I do think
the intentionality and you're great at
this Ken asking questions I think in
Winston and I have kind of gotten in
this Rhythm too instead of just say of
telling right you do that I want you to
do asking questions actually get to know
your spouse on that level of what's
what's really going on and that takes
some intentionality uh but I think
getting to the root of all of this is
key the root for her yeah why does she
not want to stick to the budget the root
for her why does she not want to go back
to work like like what what's going on
within her Y and then for him too what
what is going on I love that you're
bringing this up because we know there's
all kinds of tension around money issues
this is a really great conversation one
of the things I learned from a coach
years ago that I was getting trained by
as I was getting into this type of work
where I get to coach people they told me
to always ask what questions not why
questions you hear this in a lot of
therapy like if you're doing marriage
counseling a good therapist we we have a
mutual friend who we did some work with
both of us individually and it's was
like don't ask why questions ask what so
in this case Barry needs to get to a
question where he goes i' I've mentioned
to you that you could work um what is
keeping you from pursuing this what are
you concerned about about what are and
allow her to share her voice yes and not
be defensive cuz it's like why haven't
you applied for something yikes right
right she's immediately on the defensive
and unable to do anything but defend
herself yeah the finger pointing doesn't
get anyone anywhere yeah that's right
and that's and that is hard so yeah and
and usually too I have found Canon life
in all my years it's there's usually a
balance right she's probably not a
full-blown crazy princess over here oh
no but could there be some time you know
could there be some things here and
there that she could do to help relieve
some stress sure and for him right like
I think there's always this like there
there's usually a middle ground my guy
Barry he's a little uptight and so
little advice to Barry is hey you know
what why don't you go take on a second
job go go enjoy your life no I'm going
to tell him to go put up and she's like
and so Mary's like well Barry why aren't
you home he's like well I just really
want to knock this out and then she
starts to go well why do you feel the
need to do this yeah that could be a
little little a little passive
aggressive way to do it but it's better
than what he's doing now by emailing the
second largest Radio Show in the country
and asking is my wife of Princess create
your free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life